foreign
people welcome to a late but still
somehow on time honest trailer
commentaries for the boys that's right
the boys are back in town it's me it's
Lon and joining us at the desk expert
movie analyst and and television
Aficionado taco hi Taco
hey he's excited to be here but not
really he's very nervous very nervous so
we'll keep it mellow even though this is
not a show that
um is chill at all no the boys yeah
they're very in our face that's why he's
so nervous there's someone knows what
homelander's gonna do they have so much
attitude so we're gonna be talking about
that uh Seasons two and three we'll
watch The Honest Trailer together
um we've got a q a so put those uh in
the chat if you have any questions we
also have deleted scenes I think maybe
and uh and then we can uh tease you with
next week's on his trailer
um which is a lot fresher In My Memory
but let's go back to the Boys season two
and season three uh I don't and delay
let's go I don't have a ton to say about
it uh Beyond
um I like this show I I think it's like
uh it like fell in a time into a Time
Tunnel in 2006 and then like popped out
in in the 2020s which is actually
refreshing now because things have kind
have been glossed into a Marvel DC Sheen
and this is um this is something
different it's a little bit it's got a
little bit smarter writing going on than
than a either a traditional superhero
show or even the other attempts at
superhero satire it is I I I think it's
almost it's almost too smart in some
ways like I feel like sometimes I I feel
like the the show has so much on its
mind and it's trying to do so much
that's interesting and social commentary
that you can it's kind of two shows in
one that you kind of then feel yourself
pulled back into like well we better
drive a boat through a whale or we
better go to a superhero orgy or you
know like they're like well that's what
the people want to see is The Edge Edge
Lord stuff and so it really kind of
feels schizophrenic at sometimes like
there's this really smart thoughtful
show about celebrity culture and media
and even like creeping Fascism and all
sorts of relevant stuff about America in
2023 and then there's this kind of Dopey
repetitive show about like what if
everything was like in your face bro
well it's funny because it's always a
great match yeah the smartest stuff is
happening on the superhero side and and
Vaught and the dumbest stuff is
happening with the boys like they're
just getting covered in spew and chunks
and they there in the cartoon world and
the superheroes are in the real world
right and and like and I'm not saying I
I'm anti-all of that you're like getting
covered in chunks sometimes people get
covered in chunks and it's funny like I
I think they they do that kind of edge
Lord humor as well as anybody is doing
it it's just it feels like a little bit
of an odd mix sometimes with the more
serious mind not serious because it's
all funny but like the more thoughtful I
think you have to be a little smarter
lawn to get it it's kind of like a Rick
and Morty and me who gets it right you
have to be just smarter you just have to
kind of get to homelander's the good guy
and that's who we should be rooting and
Rick yeah uh all right that's your intro
let's watch the other trailer for The
Boys season two and three so Taco can
take a nice nap yeah
he's already feeling better
look at that tail like that guy look at
that tail
in a world overrun with nerd content
Amazon has perfected their own take on
the genre
fan speed
see this is what rings of power was
missing when you saw me there
foreign
she's got a husband yeah elfs
I can't say now because I don't want
this to also get demonetized like the uh
on this trailer but um or age restricted
at least but you know elves get down
elves do it I mean I have to like that's
part that's token in a very like stately
Enya video kind of way right yeah a lot
of people there's a lot of flowing
Fabrics there's a little tokens
supplement called elves do it
uh yeah I like Amazon's um Niche they've
carved out at least I like the boys box
Market is fine I'm not a DND guy and
then I really like invincible so you
know that's something yeah they've got
an identity I don't know how sustainable
it is to always be like The Meta the
metaverse yeah and I mean like there's
just there's so many because it Netflix
has tried to do that too what was that
one Jupiter's whatever rainbow crown
right yeah the Mark Miller verse yeah
there's there's like everybody's trying
to get into like meta takes on
superheroes because that's why it's so
so in right now but yeah I think Amazon
has like the the two best examples so
far yeah yeah well there you go no good
good for them well done their Bezos is
uh make me a Game of Thrones that maybe
didn't work out as well but uh make me a
like a weird meta take on superheroes
that that dictate that went quarter
billion dollars well spent we'll see in
season five if it brings a power paid
off I listen I liked it more than it's
fine you gotta you gotta know those
books I don't know why they did it that
way it appeals to me who does know those
books wow but I feel like the vast
majority of viewers who probably know
that story mostly through the movies
they're totally lost like I I don't I
don't get why you we want I I'm tempted
to launch in the rings of power talk but
unless we're here for the boys
join back up with the all books
government murder Squad known as the
boys
they're the good guys Huey is still
doing the will they won't they they did
who cares thing was Starlight while he
crashed a new Alter Ego as Captain Save
A Hoe let me save you for once I can
finally save you for once I saved you
Annie all I want is to save you butcher
is still finding fun new ways to lose
friends and alienate people
but who will come to learn is secretly a
father with the heart of gold and it's
gone maybe I don't want to look at you
and tagging the wall or the other ones
Frenchy mother's milk and Kimiko who
hang out in the background doing drugs
until we can all get back to the fun
Parts friend you you high well that goes
without saying yeah pause
they're not bad side characters I just
like if butcher if butcher's not on
camera I say where's Butcher and if
homelander's not on camera say where's
Homeland I know they have to build other
things into the show and build
anticipation but I'd never found of any
of their little side quests that they
give them
they're not as compelling they're just
not I feel like it's a little bit of the
like doing two seasons at a in in a row
I think really highlighted this that
it's kind of they're constantly going
back to like square one like these
characters don't necessarily move
forward it's like every season is well
here's where they're at this season and
then it kind of resolves and then the
next season is like well here's where
they're at this season and it's it's
similar yeah those are it's like like
Frenchy really wants human connection
but he's getting messed up on drugs or
mother's milk he he loves his family
he's got to get back to his family he
loves his family oh he's got to leave
his family again you know like you're
just on these sort of tracks and I don't
know if they do a great job necessarily
and I mean I get that because it's a
comic book and it's you gotta return
them to square one so they can
investigate the next superhero Thing
sure I just you know it's it's it's one
of those ongoing TV show kind of kind of
things that most shows never do figure
out even Sopranos on some level is like
well who's back in town that Tony's
gonna need to square off with this
season sure there's a little bit of that
I think it's especially noticeable with
like Frenchy mother's milk chemical
because it's a little bit like they're
kind of the same over and over mother's
looks trying to tell us something like
with he's telling a t-shirt story
because he has like a different 90s to
early 2000s hip-hop t-shirt on every
single season that's true but then he
also has like it wasn't Condoleezza Rice
but he has like like a big Barack Obama
poster and stuff like that I don't know
there's something that he's trying to
tell a story through props
doing a lot of yeah a lot of prop work
and I mean because that's the there are
it's a bustling show too like there's a
lot you've got Huey and starlight and
they're kind of your main ways in but
you've got all of the vot people like
we're following the entire seven we're
following a lot of the like Ashley and
uh whoever the staff the CEO Stanford
Edgar daughter yeah like all that stuff
and like it's it I think there's so many
characters to keep up with it yeah it's
inevitable that a few of them get the
kind of short shrift every season I mean
maybe I haven't read the comics so no
spoilers but I mean get some new Boys in
there like the boys crew like well
there's milk he's he's all right he's
good and then Kimiko and Frenchie they
go off and sail away together right and
I feel like they are they're kind of
always tempted to do that but then they
like you know well we got to bring them
around for next season we don't want to
write them out completely because that's
what I mean like you're you're in these
stories where it's always like yo I
can't do this anymore I gotta go be with
my family and they're like great okay
you think you can go on and no fumble
around
two episodes later he's back you know
like it's it's never they're never gone
I think you are right Norm for leaving
but I'll have your back it's not bad
yeah thank you you're working I'm work
shopping at live all right let's keep
going
I'm better
I am better as he shows off his awesome
powers of comparing himself to damn near
anybody Dr Martin Luther King he was
persecuted spoke truth to power just
like me the mountain to Muhammad as it
were I know exactly how he must have
felt Jesus as the scariest set of
on-screen Jaws since the shark movie
a lot of job clenching
it's definitely
I hope they gave him some gum or like a
retainer it's gonna hurt himself they
just they write this scenario so much of
like and then a person says something to
homelander that's a bit sassy they give
him so many setups can't handle it is
trying to keep it good
[Music]
great job work yeah
soar back to season two when the writers
thought hmm maybe we were being too
subtle and put a literal Nazi on the
show
this is probably what got us educated
and that's goebbles enters
rule 34 Hitler
and being a woman in her 80s who can
actually use social media when you see
it on your uncle's Facebook page then
you know it's working
how
raid-based evil will combine with CEO
Stan Edgars more numbers based evil it's
not ruthless prices per share that's all
as Giancarlo Esposito's master plan New
Year's completion play every calculating
schemer on television and animation and
video games he's just so good at it
though it's for season three when the
writer said hmm are we still being too
subtle and whipped out the Star-Spangled
go featuring Hero guys um an episode
about a super orgy that's the least sexy
part of a show where the Deep humps an
octopus had a workout huh yeah
the reveal of black no war as this
regular black guy hmm no spoilers but
not quite the same effect as the comic
reveal I did like his Happy Tree Friends
though we are so proud of you so pause
uh what's the comic room Uh Kevin
told me that it's great uh our editor
um but I didn't look it up because I
would like to be surprised
um and I don't spoil it for anyone but
if you're interested I guess that's very
different from who Blackmore is in the
comics and it was a little bit of a
letdown because it's a very cool
uncovering uh when it finally happens oh
I wonder why they wouldn't have done it
if it's cool maybe they got other plans
we'll see yeah
right he died in season three well yeah
but but it's totally different in the
comic so who knows maybe it's a clone
maybe he's coming back or I have no idea
it's like a lady stoneheart thing they
just like went their own way entirely I
don't know uh do your own research
that's true the commentary's motto uh
all right but not about this just just
vaccines yes and now we're demonetized
all right keep going devoted to newcomer
and old Comer soldier boy he may have
been winter soldiered in a Russian
prison for decades but when the boys
bust him out we'll meet Captain actual
America
shield he's yet another hole in a show
that's full of them but he's the only
chance we've got to take down homelander
unless anyone's got a cell phone handy
You're Gonna Leave Me and Elena alone or
I release this I'm in the seven
wonderful
you're not supposed to record us when
we're running lines get rid of it now
dive into the character's emotional
backstories to learn what drives their
dysfunction Huey finally gets over his
daddy issues he wasn't weak
I didn't know what strength was well his
boss Victoria must deal with her daddy
issues you're not his daughter you're
his weapon and butcher must confront his
daddy issues
snowy little while mother's milk
confronts his daddy issues you can close
the book on him once and for all for you
and when she confronts his daddy issues
before William butcher it was me for me
it was
you as soldier boy confronts his daddy
issues said it was a disappointment
not good enough to carry his name well
homelander Works through his mommy
issues
by replacing them with brand new daddy
issues just we're all on the same page
here did you know that I had a father
out there alive so pause
um yeah I feel like they did this back
in season one or it's a move that they
found they liked and stuck with which is
the uh they have a family reveal yeah
where you think oh they're such a piece
they don't care about anyone oh
oh my God that changes everything that
is the go-to for season I feel like when
the guy who created your show is also
the guy who created Supernatural That's
when you get a lot of that move got it
okay I didn't realize that
um that's why that's why Jensen said oh
soldier boy that's funny
um wow so I I was watching an interview
with Jensen Ackles who was like he did
the Hollywood like six months of Hard
Exercise and eating well uh to become a
soldier boy and he showed up on set and
and Anthony starts like just have him
put the muscles in the suit dude I'm not
in great shape like you could just you
could just build it into the costume now
yeah that's true and cobwebs is just
like regular Dad yeah
this is all fake so yeah one of the what
he he got kumailed I guess if you're
doing if you're shooting like a show
like you can't do that like constantly
like the movies is like all right I'll
take six months right really like no you
can't stay every season of TV you'd have
to just be that way for years yeah yeah
exactly you gotta time your Cycles or
whatever your protein powder you better
grab your cauliflower
brown rice and chicken injections
um yeah good times all right keep going
oh I should also pause to say if we can
keep this show going for three and a
half four more minutes we're all gonna
hear the beep we're all gonna get the
beep we're gonna turn into zombies yeah
you're gonna see us we've all live on
cast I got vaccinated like last week for
the 100th time so I'm I'm definitely
going Zombie Mode no wonder my period
started sitting next to you yeah that's
why now we understand
wait
all right press play so suit up for the
show that's a little too small for
juvenile Edge Lords but a little too
dumb and gross to recommend to anyone
without internet brain poisoning get to
the prostate in this universe that's
because that was gross
a successful superhero franchise beloved
by all possible since we're already
demonetized I didn't know you could get
to the prostate through the pee hole
it's like like you get anywhere from
anywhere like you know
like the road there's a road it's fine
there's an off-ramp yeah okay just
checking anyways keep going
[Laughter]
starring The Flash urban legend meme
Lander
Soldier Boy Kill Em that boy ain't right
The Lumineers Leon the unprofessional
the strong silent type Thor Chan Call Me
Maybe track lives yeah there it is the
dark knight dark Arc Gus fringe science
oh
was that it wait pause yeah we all got
beeped right do you guys all hear it
that was yours yeah I got it wow
crazy I'm a Zombie now that's that's
wild I didn't even notice the difference
that's why I had to bring Taco today in
case everybody turned into it go get
help Taco
all right well that was unventful
shocking oh I can't believe it didn't
trigger everyone's autoimmune response
be really funny if that happens in like
30 seconds yeah all right keep keep
playing it up the caves
[Music]
but the Japanese dub is way better
actually discover this I recommended
videos on YouTube oh my God it's
happening again
okay yeah I got mine before you wait
well so now I'm getting triggered okay
great wait who's your
who's your Verizon oh I'm on ATT okay so
you're gonna know about the missile
first yeah we pay an extra 2.99 a month
I'm phase two okay well there you go
glad we could experience that live
together uh that's uh we're done
the boys Seasons two and three
enjoy the show that feels straight out
of the naughty Audis what about us the
Spice Girls right that's even getting
its own Van Wilder College spit off in
this Ultra cynical look at our culture's
media landscape love triangles they
generate a 47 surge in trending topics
on social platform the political
environment black lives matter all lives
matter and really just anything you can
throw a curse at buy their toys and
drinking their energy drinks and going
to see their shoes that grow from season
one's what if superheroes were bad to
just what if everything was
thank you
vot I'm done
I'm done okay so no point in trying
anymore cool cool
story
huge ass
crushed red American Horror Story
super natural flight supremacist Prime
Amazon
Victoria's Secrets
we could beat Heroes that's good the
boys 18 to 35 Target demographic
do you think Amazon had to pay for that
product placement do you think State
Farm had to pay or else they get product
placement at the Cutie style girl
pageant
right there was like the little Miss
hero it's like how messed up that is
like brought to you by State Farm it's
that's all it doesn't matter as long as
they get in we're in the boys
uh context
all right uh you also have had some good
questions coming in so let's let's uh
let's hit these
um Evan's wondering because I have not
uh what do you guys think of gen V so
far I haven't seen it yet all right
neither I wanted to but I got sucked
into that uh Netflix Castlevania cartoon
oh okay cool sorry
um all right uh Arthur asked if the boys
are a take on superheroes what other
part of our daily lives deserves to have
a boys treatment
like a big satire waiting waiting to
happen oh um I thought it would be
gaming and I hear that Mythic Quest is
really good yeah
it's good but it's more like a workplace
comedy series than like a satire of
gaming okay
like you get you get inside stuff about
the gaming industry a little bit but I
wouldn't say that's the focus um
um okay I mean maybe like uh the
corporate world in general wasn't that
was it Better Off Ted or something like
that and there was also corporate on
corporate yeah okay well they tried um
there what there is from the guy I
forget what it's called but the guys who
made American Vandal did a show for
Paramount plus where it was about it was
like specifically about like Esports it
was like an Esports team yeah and I feel
like that would have been good but I
didn't I didn't see it all right well
there you go let's check those out yeah
too many things
um let's see
uh whoa well that's a rings of power
question we will save that
um we're gonna do Rings apparent it was
such a huge hit I'm sure we'll do it
James asked which Universe would you
rather live in the boys or Invincible I
don't want to live anywhere with
superheroes that's that gets glossed
over a lot um I will say I feel like
Invincible like very chaotic Universe
the chance it's like a Grand Theft Auto
superhero Universe the chances of you is
just a random bystander getting killed
there plentiful right the boys it does
happen but I feel like it's it's rare I
mean I know yeah the boys like the
heroes are the villains too but there
aren't like it's a huge deal when
there's a super villain right it's like
holy crap it's more like our world but
with like celebrities or superheroes
instead I feel like you're just as a
random civilian you're a lot safer in
the boys yes uh Evan s uh in the comics
the soups caused the damage and death of
9 11. what are the odds that gets into
the show
uh I mean they could but I know
everything just logic based it's taking
place in our it's not appear but it
could be a flashback of yeah but
honestly at this point yeah I I could
see them doing that like you could say
an evil superhero cause 911 and
flashback yeah like maybe you wouldn't
show them flying into the towers very
viscerally but like if you like it's a
joke or as it aside Americans aren't
that into it anymore we could do you
could get away with it uh and then
finally matanus uh what are the chances
that rings of power is the reason that
the viewership on streaming the WJ will
get will be under NDA Amazon does not
want to admit no one saw it I don't
think it's that show but that is why I
mean like the the reason that the
streaming platforms don't want to be
transparent overall is because they
don't want their investors to see how
few people are watching this well I
think I think what we've seen is there
are they're undeniably like big
streaming hits like we know that there
are shows that like suits this summer
like everybody watched it uh Nielsen has
confirmed there's data so I feel like
the answer is that no one's watching
anything on streaming it's that all the
views are collected in like the top 10
or 15 things on every platform if that
right and everything else isn't getting
watched and that's what they don't want
to admit that they blew billions of
dollars on these deep content libraries
and then everybody on Disney plus is
watching like the same four Pixar
episodes of Bluey yeah right and blue
yeah and right so it's like that's the
it's it's not nobody's watching it's all
the views are collected into just a few
shows yeah and I would not be surprised
if rings of power had high viewership
for an Amazon original but if you take
like view per dollar spent it's probably
not looking so good that's exactly what
it is it's not that nobody's watching as
they compared to they they needed it to
be a Game of Thrones level cultural
Juggernaut yeah to ex to make up for
that and it's like a flea bag that costs
a quarter billion dollars that is not at
all it's just blip and it's like one of
those shows people like and then they
move on to the next show and like you
can't spend a hundred mil per episode on
mayor of Kingstown yeah I could there's
just no excuse for that
um who's in that show okay I was gonna
say yeah it I really like mayor it's
good that was that's a good one yeah
uh watch mayor of Kingstown Guy renewed
coming back to season three that's your
clue for next week
um no that's not that's not a clue at
all that's a bad clue for next week
um but I said maybe you should go watch
Blue's Clues on delay yeah there you go
that's a clue for next week we'll be
back uh back to Tuesday I think yes
we'll be right this was just because I
had to be here with this this is a Doggy
Daycare now um but I hope you'll join us
next week right here on Australia
commenters thanks for watching bye-bye
thank you
[Music]